if you look at the history of football
and particularly the NFL I mean lots of
things have changed they've changed the
helmets they've changed the shoes the
change of playing surface but not the
football everything in the NFL has
gotten lighter and faster you know you
look at clips from even the 80s the
linebackers have pads on it looks like
they're carrying a house on their back
everything is sleek and fast except for
one thing the football the football
hasn't really changed you know it's
surprising that no one has considered
can we do something with the football to
help the game a big skin isn't thanks
get its pebble grain cowhide and the
football itself is really just the same
thing that has been for quite a long
time I'm a physics professor at
Southeastern Louisiana University and I
like to look at the physics of all sorts
of different things
what could you do to change the
equipment to make the game different
we're going to look at the football how
you can optimize that football so that
you could do something different what
would you do to make the ball so that
you can throw it further
they just three-step everything the NFL
has done over the last couple decades is
to increase offense and to help the
passing you you know this is the biggest
piece of equipment this is something
that they might look at changing someday
if you look at the football pass there's
really two parts the first part is when
the quarterback has the ball and the
motion of throwing the ball the
quarterback pushes on the ball and
accelerates it and then lets it go and
then after that it's in the air gravity
pulls it down but there's also an air
resistance force that pushes against its
motion
so what would you have to change to make
the ball fly differently from the air
what if you decrease the mass the ball
the quarterback could grow it and such
that it would end up with a greater
speed when it left his hand but that
would also have an impact on how it
flies to the air I mean if you threw a
ping pong ball it wouldn't go very far
at all even though it has a low mass you
have this balancing effect decrease the
mass makes it faster when it leaves a
hand but also more susceptible to the
air if you can decrease the mass the
ball down to 200 grams if you decrease
the radius from 8.8 centimeters 7
centimeters you get an extra range of
about 16 yards picture Aaron Rodgers
he's already deadly you know mid-range
to long-range maybe 35 yards 40 yards
downfield why did he get to split his
wrist and get it 65 yards downfield can
you imagine the pressure on the defense
would be able to cover basically the
whole field while on the run that's what
we're talking about here but then what
happens next how do quarterbacks
take advantage of this do they throw it
more is it harder to carry does it
bounce different there's all these other
questions that come up we can calculate
how these things might go and we can
optimize it theoretically but the game
of football is not about theory it's
about actually gets down in there and
playing the game
you